just how optimistic are analysts about
the chances of reunification a professor
of economics at berlin's university of
applied sciences joins us now sebastian
dulin thank you very much for coming in
mr deleon first of all what do you think
the chances are of a reunified cyprus
suddenly making headlines
well i'm an economist not a political
scientist but
if i just look into history
we have discussed reuniting uh cyprus
before and it has failed it's roughly 10
years ago and it was a huge
disappointment for for the european
union so i don't necessarily see what
should be different this time around and
it was a very good chance back then uh
for cyprus to to use that opportunity to
reunite at the moment though it's in a
terrible situation economically
isn't that
also an opportunity i mean
in desperation won't people really be
pushing for this this time
i mean of course you you could think so
and uh if cyprus would be reunited this
would remove some obstacles for for the
business sector uh but first we have to
see that uh the the problems of cyprus
are much larger so this uranification
would not be enough to get cyprus out of
the mess they are in and second um
especially if you have these these
conflicts like we have in cyprus
small economic benefits usually don't
trump the ethnic or political
considerations of the population how bad
is the situation at the moment gdp
shrinking six percent last year
unemployment at a record 17
um well i mean if if i get the figures
right since the beginning of the crisis
cyprus the cyber economy has shrunk by
15 percent you can now say well this is
better than greece but this is little
consultation for
for those living in cyprus so it is a
pretty deep crisis it's something for
example the germans have never
experienced after the second world war
at the same time if you look at what the
banks are lending at the moment
business landing cyprus is very
different from its other southern
southern european neighbors the latest
figures from the european central bank
show cypriot lenders giving out more
loans than a year ago it looks like a
small percentage change
but it's certainly very promising when
you compare the island uh to greece
spain or portugal the situation in
germany is a lot stronger but so is the
economy here
which brings me to my next question is
there a major imbalance developing in
cyprus
um what do you mean by imbalance
in comparison to how healthy the economy
is and what banks are actually lending
i mean you need to see that uh bank
landing and the whole banking sector has
contracted very strongly and so now this
might be the first sign of a recovery
but it is not a strong credit growth
which which would uh be the the
beginning of a very strong upswing and
you're talking about of course where um
you know disaster hit cyprus and it had
relied so much on banking hadn't it
what what can it rely on now
well this is the interesting question
because the business model cyprus had
before
probably is not viable for the future
they were an offshore banking center
which basically attracted deposits from
russian oligarchs and while other
foreigners they all had to bleed during
the crisis
because they they were bailed in
basically so they didn't get all their
money back and they will think twice
whether they will put their money again
in a cyber bank so cyprus needs to think
of something else to do but whereas the
russian bankers might have left the
island the russian tourists have started
arriving is tourism a viable
solution for the island it is possible
tourism definitely is an option but
cyprus needs to be aware that there are
other players in southern europe which
also
well put their hopes on on on tourism i
mean greece would like to have a
recovery based on tourism turkey always
has been a strong actor strong player in
tourism and northern africa might be
attractive again if they once gets get
the grips with their security issues
okay so cyprus certainly facing a lot of
challenges there thank you very much for
coming in